hey there fellow kids it's me
a human I've just come to ask what's the
deal with being a millennial student
debt am i right well it's worth noting
that I as a human also hate student debt
I don't want to be negative AF but life
can be full of fakers and what really
slaps these days is realness
you see I'm real and that's great
because today's youths want something
real something authentic
they don't want Leave It to Beaver or
those wack posers at clever crevice no
no they want a pickle rolling around in
rat feces have I asked you to test that
belly yes that you can know whenever an
episode drops we're podcast it would
really help me fill my prabhu fish I
sometimes get stabbed so subscribing the
culture binge and RSS would really do a
bluff to help my seasonal revolution
please be my friend okay in all
seriousness today I'm here to talk about
those raw authentic human emotions or at
least how the appearance of those
emotions has become a marketing strategy
for some brands and how that strategy
can help us understand things like sonic
making a hello fellow brands meme about
fan outrage or literally any Deadpool ad
character from Marvel movies we are
Marvel yeah but you know Marvel license
by Fox it's like if the Beatles were
produced by Nickelback it's music but it
sucks
the most notable recent example is
Burger King in their latest real Neal
campaign Burger King started raw doggin
reality by offering angsty alternatives
to their smarmy competitors Happy Meals
with Burger King you can finally express
yourself with the aptly named blue meal
or a salty meal which is not named for
the sweet mineral of the Gods that will
inevitably curse you with hypertension
but for feeling salty because emotions
matter in oceans available for limit on
only a select locations Burger King is
not offering any emotional spirits no
he's liable for any undesired lotions
experienced after consumption is
products because emotions matter
trademark apparent international pleas
met responsibly being real is not new
for Burger King or whoever their social
media manager is in April they asked
that their followers pour one out for
Google Plus later they simply tweeted II
of course Burger King is only one
example in 2009 Pizza Hut tweeted devour
a supreme personal pan as motivation for
my first tweet in 2017
Wendy's went viral after roasting fellow
brands and even its followers but
perhaps the most interesting development
of this is that brands are in fact
becoming people or at least their
Twitter's first person usage of the word
I suggested this in response to the
closure of iTunes Burger King tweeted
and just when I found my iTunes gift
cards brands becoming self-aware has
also been observed at companies like
Netflix HBO and seamless and of course
there's the classic first-person brand
that also gets real emotions as when
Sunny D tweeted I can't do this anymore
- which Oberer eats replied yo k bro and
Sunny D replied I'm okay even this seems
weak in comparison to what is perhaps my
all-time favorites stay comes you know
the producer of emulsified meat slices
which we did this in 2018 why are so
many young people flocking to brands on
social media for love guidance and
attention I'll tell you why they're
isolated from real communities working
service jobs they hate while barely
making ends meet and are living with
unchecked personal and mental health
problems we could conversely ask why our
social media brands trading in their
corporate cheer for human despair and
unlike stay comes I don't have a
concrete answer in this vlog but I do
have some musings first it's worth
noting that in my research this idea of
authentic and human brands seems mostly
new to the last decade or so it pops up
a few times in the 90s and early 2000s
and sometimes in the context of say
authentic products versus fake products
but now a brief google search for terms
like authentic branding or authentic
marketing shows them littered on sites
like Forbes 8 adage and a slew of other
smaller marketing blogs the idea of
realness humaneness or authenticity and
marketing and branding seems to be a
response to a basic problem identified
by Steven Brown in the Harvard Business
Review in 2003 he argued that whereas
the world war ii generation saw the rise
of the brand via mass media with fresh
eyes they were eventually replaced by
subsequent generations that were
subjected to branding since infancy as
such they were savvy er
were aware as brown notes of the
campaigners behind the campaign and as a
result they were harder to market to
this is not some brave realization of
Millennials but Gen X a realization also
held by subsequent generations Brown
locates within this problem for
marketers three strategies to reach
weary consumers one you can recruit your
consumers as corporate reservists ie
brand evangelists who just won't shut
the [ __ ] up about how much they love
Apple's new $999 stand too you can use
nostalgia around this time we had to
relaunch at the BW beetle the Star Wars
prequels and other nostalgic marketing
moves and finally there's three
hierarchies
while we may recognize it as the go-to
move of every Deadpool advertisement
Brown thought that even in 2003 ironic
marketing had overstayed it's welcome
take for instance the 90 sprite campaign
image is nothing one ad features a Sunny
D parody where a bootleg mascot
terrorizes a family
the narrator beckons us to trust your
gut not some cartoon character there's
another where we are reminded how much
money Grant Hill makes as he plugs the
refreshing taste of the lemon-lime
beverage the viewer is encouraged to
drink sprite because you like it like
his an athlete says he does a statement
made by a mega corporation paying an
athlete to star in their commercial
compare this to the Rick and Morty Old
Spice commercial where Rick counts his
ad revenue and Browns assertion that
irony was becoming old seems to have
been patently wrong but maybe there's
some kind of truth to it what all this
leads to is a problem when consumers are
inundated with branding like they
eventually see through the charade and
quickly tire is it possible that
coca-cola is only leveraging world peace
for a profit and then there's the
response companies like sprite that say
ha everybody who buys into cokes
marketing is a sucker you're not a
sucker because we just told you that in
fact you're in on our scheme to sell you
sprite this is even weirder when you
consider that Coke owned sprite of
course that message also gets old I
can't speak for all of you but even the
latest trover save the universe ad where
Rick and Morty co-creator Justin roiland
plugs his new game chapped my ass a
little bit using us to shell this
garbage you should be ashamed of
yourself and a growing number of memes
seem to suggest that people don't quite
buy that uber Bank of America or even
Taylor Swift really have the well-being
of the gay community in mind as they
cash in on Pride Month
so as Browner claims people search for
authenticity now various brands have
successfully convinced consumers that
they're more than a brand in the past
authenticity obsessed hipsters preferred
PBR to the seemingly more corporate
swill that Budweiser promoted for a
while Google also had people convinced
with their don't be evil motto and
nobody would accuse Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland of being some stuffy old
suits who make millions of dollars up a
global cartoon brand this quest for
authenticity also explains the very
structure of YouTube I literally appear
on the screen now because we realize
that people connected with on-screen
faces and not disembodied narrators and
speaking of connecting with real human
check out our podcast culture binge
Brants attempting to infiltrate this
real space with real humans has often
gone catastrophic ly wrong is rewinds I
in the world of YouTube having videos
that are over produced is a liability
rather than an asset which is why
culture binge live looks like just
kidding it's because alec is a hipster
who won't move to LA but back to the
only Mad King that I recognize the
sovereignty of if on the internet
content is increasingly in the hands of
influencers and YouTube personalities
who are on the surface more honest then
brands also need to seem more honest
so brands start using the first-person
what's more authentic than a human and
then they start roasting other brands
and then they start having depression
this isn't a fad so much as it seems
dictated by the market Pepsi essentially
tried to remake the bio world a coke
commercial for 2017 and we got this
nightmare similarly Burger King's real
meals were for the most part met with
jeers the humanization of brands has
also seen an inverse development the
brand a-- fication of humans as
entrepreneurs life coaches and every
goddamn stranger who connected to you on
linkedin will tell you to succeed
professionally you have to build a
personal brand now what does this mean
exactly I mean technically it's learning
how to sell yourself and your
professional skills but really it means
turning yourself into a commodity
stripped of all the human quirks which
may clash with that brand maybe after we
get tired of people as brands we'll go
back to looking for real people who are
just people turned brands turned back
into people what this really speaks to
is that the market will do anything to
break the pre-existing script as we
become savvy to whatever the marketing
flavor of the week is if we're used to
cynicism they'll give us authenticity if
we're bored by minimalism they'll hit us
with maximalism so are we stuck in some
sort of Perpetual pendulum swing of
authenticity and cynicism am i a real
person or just the cynical face of a
digital first media brand I guess the
only way to know is to subscribe to
culture [ __ ] which I've heard described
as mainlining reality straight into your
brain okay that never really happened
but people really love it and you can
watch me along with to add
we brand ambassadors breaking down
everything both awesome and terribly
wrong with culture today this whole
video was born out of a conversation we
had on it about Burger King's sad meals
so if you like this video you'll love
the podcast we've talked about all kinds
of great stuff like the Keanu saans how
do you guys interact with Keanu Reeves
are you guys obsessed you guys love them
as much as I do online dating I don't
even know how to translate myself into
some sort of online dating digital realm
gaming addiction so like if somebody
were to go seek therapy for a gaming
addiction the therapist shouldn't
immediately discount a game of Thrones
my girlfriend said I was talking my
sleep about Game of Thrones and more
it's available on Apple podcast Google
Play Spotify or wherever you get your
podcast links are in the description
we'll also be live-streaming weekly on
Wednesdays at 3:30 Eastern 12:30 Pacific
so hope to see you there and as always
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]